Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Was machen wir? Wir geben bekannt.
Wir wollen kurz darüber reden, was wir vorhaben zu lesen und zwar Unhaltbarkeit auf dem Weg in eine andere Moderne von Ingolfur Blühdorn. Ein Buch, das bei Surkamp erschienen ist und der Untertitel lässt uns schon aufhorchen, oder? Auf dem Weg in eine andere Moderne geht der Weg also von Ulrich Beck weiter irgendwo hin.
Also, wir wissen bisher, also ich weiß nicht mehr als den Titel und natürlich, was jetzt Soziopolis kurz dazu geschrieben hat, wer der Autor ist. Ich kann also nur kurz referieren. Ingolfur Blühdorn ist ein deutscher Politikwissenschaftler, der in Wien an der Wirtschaftsuniversität eine Professur hat, dort ein Institut für Gesellschaftswandel und Nachhaltigkeit leitet, aber als Forschungsschwerpunkt nicht nur Politik der Nicht-Nachhaltigkeit, sondern simulative Demokratie. Und das ist natürlich ein Stich ins Wespenest, denn das, was wir gerade brauchen, ist nicht simulative Demokratie, aber Szenario-Planung. Ich hatte das beim letzten Mal schon, Scott Galloway hat das kurz erwähnt. Man kann auch ruhig mal ein Szenario durchspielen, unabhängig davon, ob es wahr ist, sondern einfach nur auf seine, wie soll ich sagen, Wirklichkeitspotenziale abklopfen. Und meiner Meinung nach ist das, was wir gerade bei den Republikanern in Amerika zum Beispiel sehen, die eine Idee von einer Gesellschaft haben, die es noch nicht gibt, aber die für sie erstrebenswert ist. Die spielen also ein Szenario durch. Die haben einen völlig wahnsinnigen und wahnsinnigen Plan und versuchen jetzt ihre simulierte Wirklichkeit an die Wahrheit für uns alle heranzurücken. Und von daher ist ein Buch, das uns sagt, Fahrtabhängigkeit ist wichtig, aber ab und zu muss man mal mit dem Säbel rangehen und sich im Kopf schon mal sagen, das wird so nichts. Ihr könnt hier alle eure Ideen haben, aber bis ihr die umgesetzt habt, ist der Bus abgefahren. Kennt jeder aus seiner eigenen Planung. Man ist mit Kindern unterwegs, irgendwann muss man sagen, sorry, wir gehen jetzt los. Der Bus fährt, der wartet nicht, wir verpassen hier etwas. Und ein Buch, das uns so politisch an die Hand nimmt, wie ich hoffe, scheint mir doch Literatur der Stunde zu sein.
Er beginnt das Buch mit Sätzen, die wir alle kennen. Ende oder Wende, weiter so ist keine Option, fünf vor zwölf, sozialökologische Transformation oder Unbewohnbarkeit des Planeten. Und er sagt, seit den Anfängen der Umweltbewegung bestimmen diese und ähnliche Formeln den umweltpolitischen Diskurs. Bis in die Gegenwart werden sie wiederholt. Wir stehen am Abgrund, sagt UN-Generalsekretär Antonio Guterres im November 2022. Und dann schreibt Blühdorn, aber diese Rhetorik ist alt und stumpf geworden. Sie verfehlt die Realität spätmoderner Gesellschaften. Die Bedrohungen sind heute tatsächlich größer und akuter denn je. Doch dieses Denken verdunkelt mehr, als es erhält. Es ist an der Zeit, aus dem Dualismus von Einsicht oder Untergang, auszubrechen. Und das ist das Angebot, das er macht. Und ich finde diesen Titel so großartig. Unhaltbarkeit, weil es sowas sehr abstraktes und griffiges zugleich hat. Also etwas ist nicht mehr zu halten. Man muss es also loslassen und muss es fallen lassen. Man muss also ein anderes Denken zulassen über unsere moderne, über ökologische Transformation und auch was sonst alles gesellschaftlich möglich ist. Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, geht es ja in seinem Vorgängerbuch Simulative Demokratie darum, dass er eigentlich sagt, wir simulieren Demokratie. Aber was hat das eigentlich mit Demokratie zu tun? Und hier geht er in diesem Buch, so heißt es im Klappentext, ja so weit, dass er so eine doppelte Unhaltbarkeit zeigt. Also einmal ist das, was wir tun, nicht nachhaltig. Und zugleich gibt es da die sozial-ökologische Transformation, die nicht richtig ankommt. Und da heißt es, diese doppelte Unhaltbarkeit führt in eine andere moderne Jenseits. Und jetzt kommt es liberal-demokratischer Normen. Also ist das mit dem Liberalismus jetzt nicht mehr haltbar. Das ist ja auch in der Richtung, in die jetzt Manu argumentieren würde. Oder wir haben ja auch Fayt Selk gelesen. Und jenseits des Glaubens an die Mündigkeit der Menschen, die offene Gesellschaft und universelle Menschenrechte. Und das ist vielleicht etwas, was dich einfangen wird. Du bist ja auch jemand, der an die Mündigkeit des Menschen grundsätzlich glaubt, aber auch bei ganz vielen politischen Prozessen sagt, das ist vollkommen egal, ob die Leute das jetzt bewusst mündlich aufgeklärt tun als Objekte oder ob sie es einfach tun. Ich bin sehr gespannt, welcher Weg in die Moderne hier eingeschlagen wird.
Ja, das kann man auf die einfache Losung runterbringen. Bulldozer statt Bewusstsein. Und nicht das Bewusstsein aller, die jetzt irgendwie noch mal überzeugt werden müssen. Ich habe diesen Vortrag von Adam Toos, nachdem du den Link auch an einzelne Hörer rumgeschickt hast, auch noch mal. Wir brauchen jetzt diesen Bulldozer. Und die Triftigkeit will ich noch mal unterstreichen. Wenn jetzt jemand dann einwendet, naja, aber wir können ja jetzt nicht die öko-emanzipatorische Bewegung verraten oder was auch immer. Nee, wollen wir nicht, müssen wir aber vielleicht, denn wir sehen, überall die anderen, die anders darüber nachdenken, sind sehr viel erfolgreicher. Ja. Also wirklich grotesk erfolgreich. Das ist so peinlich, zu sehen, mit welchem Scheiß man offenbar durchkommt. Wir brauchen jetzt anderes Denken und nehmen jedes Angebot anders an. Zum Beispiel das von Blühdorn.
Ja, also wir sagen nochmal den Titel Unhaltbarkeit auf dem Weg in eine andere Moderne. Das werden wir also im Salon besprechen. Wer den Salon hören möchte, kann es sich ganz leicht machen. Einfach auf die Seite neuezwanziger.de gehen. Dort oben ist ein goldener Salon-Button. Dann wird man gleich zu Steady hingeführt und dann ist alles selbsterklärend. Man kann diesen Podcast dann überall hören, wie man möchte, wie man auch den Neuen Zwanziger-Podcast hört. Das ist also nicht gebunden an diese Seite, sondern man bekommt einen persönlichen RSS-Feed. Außerdem kann man auch diesen Podcast über Patreon abonnieren. Wenn man schon einen Patreon-Account hat, ist das eine Option sicherlich. Und es gibt auch die Möglichkeit, das über Apple zu tun. Und das musst du jetzt sagen, wie das funktioniert, denn ich bin ja gar kein Apple-Kunde.
Genau, es ist nur ein bisschen teurer. Aber für die Leute, die eh auf ihrem iPhone unseren eigentlichen, ursprünglichen Neuen Zwanziger-Feed hören, da sind ja die Salon-Folgen einfach mit eingewoben. Und da kann man dann einfach auf Ja, will ich hören, man muss nur vorher mit einem Klick bezahlen. Also man kann den Salon überall hören. Spotify, Apple Podcasts, alle Podcast-Apps, die man auch so im Gebrauch hat. Da liegen keine Hürden außer die Paywall. Ja, sehr gut. Alles weitere dann Ende des Monats.
Und wir sprechen dann auch über das Familienwahlrecht, das Kinderwahlrecht. Und wir können auch noch den Bulldozer gleich mitnehmen, denn wir müssen darüber nachdenken, inwieweit wir bereit sind, die Demokratie instrumentell zu gebrauchen. Oder ob wir jetzt immer sagen Nein, die Demokratie, dieser wunderbare Himmel, der Gleichheit und so weiter. Ja, vielleicht nicht. Und dann kann man auch vor diesem Hintergrund noch mal über das Familienwahlrecht anders diskutieren. Ich bin gespannt. Ich beobachte mich noch ein bisschen.
Wir verhandeln beide mit Bulldozern in unserer Diskussion, glaube ich.
So machen wir es.
Sehr gut.
Bis dann, Leute.